there is growing concern this morning
over where navigation app sometimes tell
you to go homeowners in the Los Angeles
neighborhood say Waze is creating
dangers by diverting drivers onto a
faster route up one of the city's
steepest roads people who live there say
it's led to a number of crashes and
spinouts Carter Evans is on Baxter
Street in Los Angeles Carter boy good
morning good morning as you can see
Baxter Street is a completely blind Hill
drivers can't see what's on the other
side here until they come over the top
now if they get scared and stop or back
up that can cause a traffic nightmare
here and if you think this road looks
scary now well you should see it at rush
hour it's bumper-to-bumper traffic on
Baxter Street as Los Angeles commuters
make their way home
Jeff Hartman has lived here for 20 years
and says he's never seen it this bad
what do you think is responsible for the
increased traffic on this street oh
definitely the GPS apps the app most
people here blame is ways so it happens
when you put in an address across town
this is the normal route but you can see
it's all full of traffic so what it's
doing is its routing us through here
right down Baxter Street but Baxter
Street looks more like a roller coaster
track with a 30% grade making it one of
the steepest streets in the country even
steeper than San Francisco's
world-famous Lombard Street and are they
prepared for it when they get here I
don't think so when you get to the top
you can't see the hill on the other side
or that Street so people tend to stop
and that's where a lot of the problems
come Hartman is seen at all cars flipped
into his neighbor's yard or stalled and
slipping down the hill in the rain his
neighbors have documented a number of
dangerous accidents they took out my
trellis my retaining wall my picket
fence it looked like a plane crashed in
my front yard you lost control of the
car and ended up rolling over two
driveways it's even worse for bigger
vehicles that can get stuck at the top
when their wheels lose traction and it's
not just in LA GPS based apps are
creating problems in cities across the
country people will do whatever the app
tells them to do and it's scary
sometimes the city of Leonia in New
Jersey solved the problem by restricting
side street
to residents only during rush hour which
caused ways to remove the shortcuts as
for Baxter Street in la ways told CBS
News that since the city is placed a
public road there it should be
considered usable within ways
neighbors say ways needs to do a better
job of warning drivers and say the
problem can't be curbed soon enough
screeching and honking and sirens and
insanity all the time
la city officials basically say they
could make this a one-way street or they
could even restrict some turns on to
Baxter Street and that might rule it out
as a shortcut way says it encourages
drivers to report hazardous conditions
including steep inclines and it often
uses that information when it revises
its Maps Nora all right Carter thank you
I mean I know I use Waze a lot yeah
we'll consider that reporting that two
ways houston we have a problem there
they might want to rethink that
absolutely good